how many of you follow accounts that are
all reposted content like funny memes
funny things that happen at the gym girl
humor guy humor those are the best
accounts to follow and you can find a
niche that relates to your business
Outsource that to a VA it's time to find
that content and post three times a day
and then you don't have to live your
life on your phone let me give you an
example push me daily is my account for
adults with ADHD I don't touch it it's
all a VA and all they do is they scroll
through ADHD content they find something
funny that works adult wise they share
that content to our page and that's it
who am I attracting people with
yeah I know what problem they have it's
Focus I have a physical business where
we sell journals productivity journals
that are designed by someone with ADHD
from time to time probably at least once
a week we're promoting the journals to
that page not to the feed in stories
it's the link in the bio so that account
is generating targeted customers